hello in this video I will talk about
organs of immune system so our immune
system is just comparable to a defense
system of a country a defense system of
a country has all its defense division
its Air Force it's special task force
its Navy everything like that so our
body also has all those kind of
divisions of immune system now just like
every country has its barrier has its
border secured by fences and army
patrolling near defenses our body also
has skin which works like a physical
barrier through this fence terrorists or
outer immigrants cannot come directly in
because there are armies who who are
actually securing the border just like
that our skin is a physical barrier now
skin contains a lot of proteins and
short peptides which are ready to combat
microbes and jobs
these proteins include lysozyme cap
protecting lactoferrin defense in cattle
and Essene etc and etc all these
proteins have anti bacterial property
the interfere with some life processes
with the bacteria or other charms and
don't allow pathogen to come in also the
pH of the skin is tightly regulated such
that pathogen growth or bacterial growth
on our skin is prohibited this is how
our skin works like a physical barrier
now we would talk about primary lymphoid
organ because our immune system has two
major depletion in terms of organs
primary lymphoid organ and secondary
lymphoid organ primary lymphoid organs
are those organs when immune cells
develop so the primary immune primary
lymphoid organ
in our body is bone marrow and thymus
bone marrows are mostly found in long
bones such as depicted here in the
picture so inside that blood inside that
bone there are bone marrow in Austria
niche there are Hospital niche around
the blood vessels which circulating
around the inside the bone now bone
marrow has a meta poetic pluripotent
stem cell that means it can give rise to
all kind of blood cells then américo
etic pluripotent stem cell divides into
myeloid progenitor or a lymphoid
progenitor from the lymphoid progenitor
the adaptive part of the immune system
develops whereas from the myeloid
progenitor mostly the innate immune
system develops lymphoid progenitor give
rise to immature P cell immature T cells
and natural killer cell whereas Milo
progenitor give rise to macrophages
monocytes pand basophils pan neutrophils
etc etc now another important primary
lymphoid organ is thymus thymus is known
as the training school for the T cell T
cell are born inside the bone marrow but
in the immature state they are sent to
their school which is thymus they go to
the thymus receive thymic training
intense training they receive there in
the thymus and become mature T cells
either a helper t-cell a reserve bench
of army or direct cytotoxic cd8 positive
T cells that means combat-ready army so
here is an image of thymus in a
cross-sectional view you can see there
is sequential development happening
inside the thymus there are stages known
as double positive stages where there is
an equal chance that are immature T cell
can become either a helper T cell or a
serial positive T cell but sequentially
when they interact with follicular
dendritic cells those
P cells which choose to choose to choose
to recognize antigens on class 2 MHC
molecules they became the cd4 + helper
cells and those who choose to recognize
+1 bound peptides are becoming cd8
positive size toxic T cell now also the
secondary lymphoid organs are actually
places where the T cell or B cell or any
immune cell does not develop but they
just differentiate there it doesn't they
are not drawn they born there but they
are brought up in that places so
secondary lymphoid organ one of the most
important secondary lymphoid organ is
lymph node because lymph node is kind of
all around the body and several
lymphatic vesicles bring in lymph to
lose names node and also lymph node is
connected by veins and arteries so lymph
node is just like a army base camp so
inside the army base camps there are
different areas just like that there are
different areas for resigning of t-cell
and b-cell it is heavily compared to an
army base when there are several
barracks where different divisions of
army members can leave for example in
the lymph node inside the germinal
Center or lymphoid follicle b-cell
resides where in the para cortex t-cell
resides now we talk about the biggest
secondary lymphoid organ of our body
which is plane spleen is specialized for
trapping blood-borne antigens skin is a
encapsulated organ just underneath the
liver and it is highly vascularized and
it has a lot of blood supply since then
blood can take on the blood-borne
pathogen and dump it into the spleen now
spleen is known as the drei vier of
RBC's so our visas are recycled and also
spleen is a
compared as a big army base so there are
definitely barracks for T cells and the
B cells so if we take a look at the
cross-section of a spleen we would find
two major region one is a red pulp one
is a white pulp now in the white pulp
region it forms actually a sleeve like
area around the our trios so this is
known as peri artery or
peri arteriolar lymphoid sheep or easily
known as pulse and this is the house or
T cell whereas there are some follicles
around the pulse which is the house for
the B cells now just like the infinite
spleen is also home for t-cell and
b-cell so those are the base camps now
Anna other secondary lymphoid organs are
mucous associated lymphoid tissues they
decide in respiratory tract they decide
in many other places but one of the most
important is the Pierce patch where's
patch is found in the intestine so it's
a patch of lymphoid tissue present in
the intestine which also houses several
T cells macrophages and dendritic cells
which are important or secondary organs
for immune system so that concludes my
video on organs of the immune system so
if you like my video give it a quick
thumbs up please like my video subscribe
for more updates and don't forget to
share this video among your friends
thank you